- [Kelsey] Here's a stop light coming up
but instead of going up the stop light,
I'm gonna cut through this
little restaurant parking lot
and beat the system!
(light electronic music)
- We're fucked, you know that right?
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like we lowkey can't use a street light.
- What? Wait, what?
- Did you watch any of
the Black History Month
specials as a kid?
- See, these are the things
that they need to teach us about
a little bit harder, a little bit longer,
a little bit stronger,
a little bit louder.
- Oh, okay.
- Cause I feel like I only
know like two black inventors
that were talked about
the same way that like
Edison and Einstein were talked about.
Now I have a feeling you're
about to drop a list on me
of things I didn't know were
invented by black people.
(ding)
(hip hop music)
I know for sure this was
invented by a black man. (ding)
I don't know why I remember
that, but it makes me happy.
- Black guy.
- This is a-
- A mic.
- A microphone.
- An old school one.
- But more specifically it
looks like something like
a sexy jazz singer might sing into.
- Oh.
Oh girl.
- I'm gonna go with...
- White guy. (buzz)
- No. (ding) Black person, white person.
- Black person, black person.
This I believe is made
by a white guy. (buzz)
- Well, Ford, those were white dudes.
- Mm-hm.
- I'm gonna go with white dude. (buzz)
Um, white man, we established
that, right? (buzz)
- Mm-hm. Yeah.
- Unless this is a trick.
How wrong were we?
Shit!
- You're lying!
Damn!
- Look at what fucking U.S.
history American public school
teaches you that Thomas Edison.
- Cousin came through.
My cousins came through.
- Mine did not.
My first instinct was to
go straight to my phone.
Guess I have to buy a
calendar this weekend too.
Okay, so I literally just left the shoot
and I'm already breaking the
rules because I need to vlog
and I need my phone to vlog
so this is gonna be tough.
This is gonna be a little
tougher than I thought.
Damn, near fucking everything that's like
necessary for living just
like a basic American life
was invented by a black person.
- So, essentially I've
broken every single rule
because everything around me
was invented by a black inventor.
- The first thing I did
as soon as I left here
was I went and I got some
food out of the canteen.
Did you guys know potato chips
were invented by a black person.
See, education.
- Wow.
- What can I eat then?
Healthy shit.
Alright, I'm gonna eat
this fucking rabbit food.
- I was supposed to meet up with a friend
so I went to a coffee shop and
then my friend got mad at me
because I didn't have my laptop.
I had my laptop but I
didn't use my laptop.
I totally broke all the rules
and I brought my laptop with me.
I don't think I can
live without my laptop.
- Immediately went home
and the first thing I did
when I walked into my house was I said,
'Alexa, turn on everything.'
It's just automatic.
'Alexa, turn off everything.'
Well, it's only 6:45
and it is dark in here
because I realized that I
had a candle but no matches.
So I'm sitting in this Uber
and of course I am running late
because my alarm didn't go off
and I have now definitely
become that friend
who's an hour and a half
late because, you know,
I didn't get that text code.
- Alright, so I realize
I'm not supposed to drive
but I woke up late this morning
and I forgot that I had an
appointment to do my taxes.
I fucked up. Ah!
But I decided to take this
street that is only stop signs
instead of going on Sunset
Blvd which is down there
with all the street lights.
I'm doing stop signs.
- Technically, I'm breaking the rules.
So, me being in light
right now, I technically-
- We're gonna start listening to music.
- Listen to music and the
microphone on this phone.
I'm pretty much breaking
about like five rules.
So I'm in the elevator, (buzz)
because out to the club
and I don't feel like going
up 10 flights of steps
so y'all just gonna have
to fucking deal with it.
- For me it was like every
time I got on the stairs
or like past a stop light or whatever
it became like a fun fact in my head
then I would like share it
with whoever I was with.
Ian, did you know that stop lights
were invented by a black man.
- No. I had no idea.
- And also-
The thing, the like go
around that I learned
was that I could use
other people's things.
- Ha.
- So like instead of me driving
I made my boyfriend drive.
Do you think that counts?
Or is that some white people shit?
- It's some white people shit.
- Fuck.
- Oh wait.
It's in the refrigerator.
Really difficult living
without refrigerated items
because black people invented everything.
- Kate!
- Yeah.
- If I told microphones
were invented by a black man
would you believe me?
- Sure.
- Did you also know light bulbs
invented by a black person.
- Didn't know that.
- But here's the thing is I figured
here's where I'm doing okay
is that normally you would use microphones
to record a podcast.
- There's a microphone in our phone.
- But we're gonna use our phone
microphone so it's not like-
- Yeah, it's still a microphone.
- Listen, this is a very hard video, okay!
- We can't do a podcast if
we don't use a microphone,
thank you for inventing it.
- Thank you.
- [Joyce] Look at you cheating.
Black invention, black invention.
- The computer, ladies and
gentleman, is a black invention.
- [Joyce] Yes.
- I'm at work. I have to use
my computer at work, Joyce.
- [Joyce] Uh-huh.
- So is it what you're saying that it's
impossible to go as a person-
- In the world
- [Kate] In society without using things
that black people invented.
- Okay, so we're rounding
out day three here.
I think the hardest
part of this experience
has definitely been the no computer aspect
and I now know that I have Dr.
Mark Dean to thank for that
and I wish I would've
learned that earlier.
Gosh imagine how far worse we
would be without these things.
You know what I mean, like.
- I had takeout for three days.
- At first I was like
'Man, I feel guilty that I
didn't know all of this shit.'
And it's not so much that I feel guilty
that I didn't know about this shit,
it's more that I feel guilty
that I still live in a society
that doesn't recognize this kinda stuff
as important as white inventors
and that's what made me be like
'Damn, okay, I have some work to do.'
(upbeat hip hop music)